Pubic hair!
It's awesome!
Well, according to
me-- and also science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everyone.
Welcome to DNews.
I'm Laci Green.
There's a noticeable
trend these days
toward removing pubic hair, a
fad that's pretty new, given
that in the past it
wasn't as much of a thing.
Definitely not in the '70s.
Our parents loved their pubes.
As far back as the 1400s,
pubic hair was fashionable.
In fact, if someone
had to remove it,
like if they had lice, there
were pubic wigs called merkins
that people would wear until
it grew back, which I actually
just think is
hilarious, a pubic wig.
Gripes that we hear
these days about oral sex
and pubic hygiene
are relatively new.
And so, too, are the
array of razors, tweezers,
electric shavers, waxes,
creams, expensive hair removal
procedures, all with the aim
of keeping you clean and sexy.
But is pubic hair really
that dirty and terrible?
Scientifically speaking, no.
Pubic hair itself
actually serves
some important
evolutionary functions.
It's a protector
of the treasure.
It exists to provide a
bumper from the irritating
friction of sex.
It also serves to keep harmful
bacteria and pathogens out.
Pubic hair also harbors
pheromones, an erotic scent
unique to each person
that you subconsciously
pick up on in a partner.
There are more obvious
practicalities as well.
If you have sensitive
skin, shaving super sucks.
It can be irritating because the
hair removal inflames the hair
follicles, which can
cause itchy, burning,
nasty discomfort.
This irritation, when paired
up with the moist environment
that is the genitalia,
creates a perfect place
for unpleasant bacteria to grow.
Strep, staph boils, cellulitis,
and pustules on the genitals
are more common in people
who shave regularly.
Shaving and waxing also make
you more vulnerable to sexually
transmitted
infections that spread
by touching such as
herpes or genital warts,
because it's easier to contract
with little tiny openings
in your skin.
Of course, shaving isn't a
certain recipe for disaster,
and lots of people
do it, and they
don't get pustules or
herpes or anything terrible.
It can be fun, a way to change
it up to feel extra sexy.
But it is a personal thing that
in light of the medical facts
isn't necessarily for everyone.
Basically, you should be free
to do you, whatever that is.
All right, guys.
You knew it was coming.
What's your pubic
hair preference?
Do you like to shave,
trim, grow it out?
Let me know down
below and don't forget
to subscribe for more DNews.
[MUSIC PLAYING]